Eric you have a book that's coming out
right now we're filming this in August
but by the time this airs it'll be
September late September I believe and
your book is called the idea the seven
elements of a viable story for screen
stage or fiction curious what prompted
you to write the book yeah so I've been
a screenwriter for like 25 years and for
the last about ten years I've been
teaching screenwriting I've been working
one-on-one with a lot of writers as like
a consultant or coach and I've been just
reading a lot of scripts film and TV
scripts many many many many many scripts
right so you in trying to help writers
and to try to kind of codify principles
of writing which is always a touchy
thing because sometimes people feel
writing can't really be taught or
shouldn't be taught you know I've really
tried to figure out what are the things
that one really needs and a story idea
because people don't necessarily seem to
know when they're writing but when
someone reads someone's script they
often are having negative reactions and
what are the reasons for those reactions
I really made it my business to figure
out like what are the sort of essential
things that people are reacting to not
only when they read a script but when
they even hear the idea for a script
because the reason the book is called
the idea is that I've really come to
believe that the most important part of
the process most writers bypass too
quickly which is selecting the idea and
understanding what makes a viable idea
that is so important to the eventual
success of any project and I mean that
might seem obvious but the average
writer myself included tends to want to
get to writing they tend to want to just
start structuring outlining and writing
the script so you pick an idea you often
don't vet the idea with professionals or
friends or anyone you just kind of like
I sort of like this idea I think I'm
gonna write this and then you go about
writing it whereas in the industry if
you have a manager or an agent what I've
learned is that they'll want you to run
your ideas past them before you even
start one they don't want you to spend
your time and energy on something they
don't think is viable in the marketplace
to begin with so if you're trying to
write for that marketplace if you're
trying to get or maintain a
you're an agent and move forward you
know in like the Hollywood marketplace
what's gonna happen to you is your
representatives are gonna shoot down a
lot of your ideas which has happened to
me and they're gonna really stop you at
the idea stage and want to hear the
logline or the basic the basic premise
or pitch so I as a writer having agents
had to live that lifestyle of I got to
impress my agents first right once I'm
lucky enough to have one as someone
reading people's scripts as a kind of
consultant or teacher I now realized
what my agents were thinking because
most of the things people bring to me
finish scripts the most of the notes
that I have on their scripts are notes I
would have had on the basic idea if they
had just brought it to me when it was a
log line or a 30-second pitch or a
one-page synopsis the kind of you put in
a query so but most writers don't kind
of realize that because they haven't
vetted the idea with anyone so I've been
blogging for five to ten years now you
know little tips and things that little
pieces of wisdom that I feel I've come
up with having read all these scripts
and seeing the kind of things that I see
writers are doing and the blog
eventually led to the idea to do a book
and the book is about let's focus on the
idea what makes a viable idea it's not a
book about the whole process of
screenwriting it's not about story
structure per se it's not about writing
scenes it's not about navigating the
business although all those things are
touched on it is exclusively about what
makes a viable idea and let's slow down
writers and really work on getting the
idea right before we you know write the
script or even outline the script so
what makes a viable idea so I came up
with this little acronym of the word
problem because I feel that every story
is really about a problem and it's all
about you know when someone's are
reacting to your script or your pitch or
your logline what they're mostly
thinking consciously or not is okay
what's the problem with the center of
this story does this problem sound
really compelling and entertaining to
watch is an audience gonna care about
this problem that this main character or
these characters are trying to solve
whether it's film television or even
commercial fiction or theater
I think the same kind of basic premises
of you know how story and ideas for
story work applies to all them which is
why the title mentions stage and fiction
they're looking at what the problem is
what's the nature of the problem or
what's the nature of the goal for the
main character right so I took problem
and I created this acronym from the
letters in the word problem and the book
is basically a presentation of these
seven elements that start with those
seven letters and those are the elements
that I think successful commercially
viable stories that would interest an
age and a manager a producer and editor
etc tend to have you want to hear what
they are so it's just quickly and we can
go deeper if you want the problem at the
center of the story needs to be
punishing relatable original believable
life-altering entertaining and
meaningful so some of those words I
could have used different words but they
wouldn't fit the problem so I kind of
made it so they all lined up with those
seven letters that's great and and did
you before sort of even formulating the
idea for this book no pun intended go
through other scripts and really hone in
on what's the problem let's say some of
the blockbusters or maybe even indie
films what really is the core of this
problem and then work backwards well
yeah I do that all the time it's just a
natural thing whenever I'm watching
anything I am assessing what is the
central to me that's what the story is
what's the central problem here we could
talk examples if you wanted but pretty
much any genre it's about characters who
are kind of punished usually as they're
trying to resolve some situation and so
it's just becomes second nature to me to
think in terms of what's the problem at
the center of any TV series TV episode
movie story in general and of course
when I look at someone's script or I
just see the log line even I'm like I
said I'm looking at what's the problem
here and sometimes the log line doesn't
even make the problem clear or it
focuses too much on the internal problem
for the characters because sometimes
writers confuse like internal character
arc with external problem and great
stories generally have both but the
external problem is kind of the part
that people really want to know about
when they are assessing your idea it's
like the external problem has to be
really solid the internal arc is a
little more optional but you've got to
have that big external problem typically
in a commercial type project and so
that's what I'm talking about more than
the internal what the character needs to
learn and how they need to grow stuff
which is the arc or the theme or the
flaw you know that kind of stuff
sometimes we writers tend to focus a lot
on that and make that drive all of our
efforts and what I've learned is it's it
tends to be better to let that stuff
stay a little flexible until you've
gotten the sort of external problem
worked out and even kind of structured
out a bit because sometimes your sense
of what the theme is or what the
characters growth should be will change
and shift once you've really explored
the external problem the external
challenge that they're you know every
scene is typically about them grappling
with and trying to resolve I love that
you've chosen the word punishing whether
it was just coincidence because it
starts with P but because you're putting
yourself in the protagonists shoes and
it seems like if you're looking through
life through the lens of that character
that it is a punishment for you know
that that they are enduring things that
are unfair to them so I like that you've
chosen that as because it really is sort
of the journey of it of a character to
see it as this is a punishment now I've
got to prove that I'm innocent kind of
thing thank you yeah I mean I I think
even in even in comedy series on
television one thing I often find myself
reminding myself in my own projects and
telling other writers that come to me
and want feedback and stuff is that your
characters should really be in hell and
under siege pretty much all the time
like even if you watch a show like 30
rock means they're slightly dated
references now but like Everybody Loves
Raymond but I could also talk about like
veep or Glo or current series if you
really look at what's going on for the
characters that we're following it's
basically their suffering they're under
siege they're in a sort of hell and
they're trying to get out of it pretty
much every episode for us as an audience
it's fun to watch it's fun to watch
their reactions to things and just sort
of how their characters operate and
interact in a comedy in a drama or a
thriller it's fun a different way for
the audience it's fun for us it's never
for them you know even in even in the
you know the the save the cat book the
Blake Schneider book he talks about the
fun in game section which is the first
half of Act two in a screenplay in his
world and I think he makes some great
points but the fun and game section even
in that section of the movie which he
calls flooding games I'm all often
telling people I don't think your
characters should so much be having fun
or enjoying the situation your
characters are kind of under siege even
in the first half of Act two they're
kind of struggling suffering being
punished by the situation they're in the
upside-down world they find themselves
in the problem or goal that they're
trying to resolve which they're an
underdog and they're overmatched and the
world is not giving them what they want
that's pretty much every story in my
view in every genre so it's it's it's
interesting how often writers tend to
write scenes of characters kind of
getting along and kind of having
victories and ice and I usually say that
you know in a story the victories
generally only come at the very end if
they come anywhere other than the very
end they're usually very short-lived and
often overshadowed by the bigger problem
that still demands resolution because
what keeps the drama or the comedy
moving is that sense of there's a
problem I'm trying to solve this problem
there's this goal I'm trying to reach
this goal problem and goal are kind of
two sides of the same thing
some stories the goal is just to solve
the problem in other stories the goal is
its own positive thing and the problem
is I haven't reached the goal so it's
kind of like problem / goal I think of
it as like the same thing but that being
difficult and unresolved and also
changing and evolving and usually
getting worse and more complicated over
the course of the story or the TV
episode or the TV series is kind of this
key thing that I'm always looking at
many audiences and certainly industry
professionals are looking at and
evaluating consciously or not do I feel
the problem is compelling and big is it
getting worse you know are the
characters struggling is it changing and
evolving but generally in a direction of
worse and more difficult until the kind
of final battle at the end where
the resolution finally happens so that's
why problem is that word that I think
I'm always referring to when I'm talking
about a story so you say that writers
don't spend enough time making sure that
the idea that they're sort of putting
out there is viable wouldn't you you
think that most writers are using an
idea that's very personal to them in
some sense even if it's the story's not
really about them it's a core idea that
affects them why wouldn't it translate
if it's so personal and deep and rich to
that writer wouldn't putting something
so sort of deep and personal that the
writer is choosing a focus on be enough
to make the script viable well that's a
great question first let me say when I
talk about writers I'm talking about
myself too because I'm a writer and
that's still the main thing I do and I
make these things that I might call
mistakes so it's not me on HIGH saying
oh those writers what idiots they hire
its me saying we all naturally do this
stuff I just wanna make that clear to
your audience sure but that's a great
question and and I've made I don't I
wouldn't called a mistake but I've done
this myself many times which is write
something that is personal to me that I
think I felt something deeply about so
audiences will - and one often we know
one hopes they can pull that off and
there are some pitfalls in that approach
that often happened one of them being
that we so internalize what we went
through what we were thinking and
feeling and why it mattered so much to
us in our life to put it actually on the
page in a way that audience is looking
at a character based on us having
experiences based on ours for the
audience to get those things that are
internal to us is harder than it looks
and often just because we felt it deeply
doesn't mean that we can write a
character feeling that same thing deeply
and the audience will get it sometimes
they will sometimes those are the best
movies but a lot of times they won't and
a lot of times that thing that we went
through in our personal life that
mattered so much to us doesn't
necessarily have the ingredients of an
entertaining to watch story for an
audience like a movie or television
audience a story that builds and
complicates and gets worse and are
really fun to watch way often when we're
writing real life and this is any kind
of true
story and I've worked a lot on true
stories and people come to me a lot with
true story because I worked on Band of
Brothers for instance it's it's kind of
where I got my start professionally what
I've really learned is that true stories
are sometimes harder than fiction
because you real life doesn't have story
structure typically real life doesn't
have the things that we writers have
learned that audiences need to be really
emotionally invested and entertained and
to stay emotionally invested entertained
over the course of an hour half hour or
two hours it just doesn and writers have
to bring a lot of manipulation to a true
story to make it comprehensible to an
audience and to make it be that kind of
emotional journey with that kind of
classic narrative build to it and
entertainment value to it it just
doesn't come naturally we have to kind
of impose it so a lot of times the
things we've gone in our own life we
don't have perspective on them we can't
see them from that third party person
that has a very different life from us
and how do we portray it on the page or
on screen in a way that they will be
really entertained and invested in this
character like us and often we aren't
able to write that character with enough
perspective and enough clarity so that
people will get what they're going
through because to us it's already so
obvious it's like a given it's inside of
our head but getting it outside of our
head and onto the page in a way that
others will really get it I think it's
harder than it looks
and so when you're identifying an idea
for a story coming from a place that is
something passionate to you or that you
have experienced I think is a good start
but it's usually not enough you usually
have to sort of test it by putting
yourself in the shoes of a sort of third
party anonymous viewer with a different
life story than yours how do you make
this something that's that's universal
because our own pain in our own drama
and our own situations don't necessarily
have deep and compelling universally
relatable elements to them that any one
or millions of people would be able to
instantly grasp and be emotionally
invested I use that term a lot of
emotional investment because to me
that's the key thing we're always going
for there's an audience that's the key
thing
you want we want to care and a lot of
this focus on the idea is about finding
an idea that people you know people
strangers millions of strangers will
have a chance of really caring about
this idea caring about this character
these characters in this situation what
makes them care and so these seven
elements a lot of it is about me trying
to put into words here are the qualities
that I think are inherent in stories
that can make an audience care and when
it's coming from our own life experience
a lot of times some of those elements
could be missing and we may not realize
it when a writer brings their work to
you or even from hearing from agents
who've had a writer bring work to them
what sort of telltale signs appear when
it's so deeply personal and you can tell
that that writer doesn't have enough
perspective where is when you can maybe
tell that it's sort of loosely based on
a multitude of people and there's a
little more definition to the problem or
maybe there's not and I'm just
projecting that yeah I don't know if
there are telltale signs because you
never know when you're reading something
is this the author's own life story I
mean you can suspect it but you know
some you know I would say the absence of
some of these elements we're talking
about the like the seven elements of
what the problem you know the absence of
those is the main thing that a reader is
noticing that it isn't that entertaining
to watch or it isn't the stakes aren't
life-altering it doesn't seem like or
the character isn't relatable or the
problem isn't punishing enough or what's
going on isn't believable enough you
know those kind of things are what we're
just noticing right away once we notice
them we may speculate that oh this is
because it's their own true story and
their own true life situation doesn't
have those elements but we don't really
know for sure so I don't know that I can
say oh I can tell this is like a too
personal true story thing necessarily
unless I really know the writer and it's
pretty obvious that it's their life it's
more that the sort of absence of some of
those elements not appearing as strongly
as we would want makes us less enthused
about the script and it may or may not
be because it was a personal you
no story like that do you remember the
first feedback you received from a third
party that these elements needed to be
more pronounced was that for you
devastating and terrible in the first
moment of my life of twit what I guess I
had a pretty good life if the worst
moment of my life is having someone you
know tear apart a script but I mean yes
some of the early scripts that I wrote I
would probably cringe at now that I mean
some of the stuff I write now I probably
cringe at six months this is not an easy
feel that's what I'm saying
you always have perspective on what
you're writing yourself and whether
others are gonna respond well to it but
you know I had people say there's just
not enough conflict
it needs more conflict and I in my early
days thought conflict meant like people
arguing or fighting or car chases or
something like I didn't really know what
that meant exactly and so I didn't write
scripts and I didn't love movies that
were all about people constantly arguing
or fighting or car chasing right so I
thought I was writing something that was
the kind of stuff I would like but a
third party reading it said you know you
did some good things here I just felt it
needed a more conflict I didn't really
know what they meant now after doing it
for years and reading a lot of scripts I
know what they meant and to me conflict
is synonymous with problem so it's not
that your character has to always be in
an obvious conflict with other people
and expressing and fighting all the time
or arguing it's that they have to be in
conflict with their situation meaning
they have to have problems whenever your
character doesn't have a problem and
isn't actively even and struggling
against or trying to resolve a problem
the audience tends to check out a bit
right so that usually does lead to
conflicts with other characters trying
to solve a problem in life generally
leads to some interpersonal calm because
a lot of problems that are big enough
for a movie that we want to solve or big
enough for a TV show are problems that
involve relations and interactions with
other people so there will be conflict
but it's not that limited version of
what I thought conflict meant when I got
that critique so the problem not being
punishing enough which is like the
letter P the first one in the you know
the word problem in my book was probably
the first thing that I grappled with in
my own stuff of people
saying it's just not enough conflict
meaning it's not a big enough problem
it's maybe not a life-altering enough
problem which is the l word which is
about the level of the stakes of the
problem why does it matter that they
solve this problem why does the audience
care whether they solve it or not is it
big enough and is it relatable enough
which is the R word where the audience
is starting to feel like it's our
problem too we are standing in the shoes
of this character as they try to solve
this problem and we feel something about
it we want it to be solved because it's
kind of like it's us now that emotional
engagement with the character is like
the really key thing we're trying to
achieve as writers that was not easy to
achieve and sometimes writers don't
realize that things necessary to kind of
achieve that which is a lot of the kind
of relatable stuff so my first critique
of something not punishing enough was
probably also wasn't big enough stakes
why do people relate to this character
because you didn't find that sort of
universal hook that pulled people in the
character didn't have those elements
that make the audience just start to
feel like I'm bonded with them which is
such a key part for me like the
beginning of any screenplay what save
the cat calls the setup section I think
the first 10 pages it's all about
achieving that bonding with the audience
and and you know people often talk about
you know people put down a script in the
first 10 pages if it's not grabbing them
and writers tend to think oh you grab
them by having really exciting spectacle
in the beginning with really high stakes
what action or entertainment value which
is always helpful but to me the more
important goal in those first 10 pages
is to introduce your main character at
some length and it's some breadth and
some depth in such a way that the
audience starts to see what the key
things are that would make us care about
them what makes them a compelling
relatable person even before the main
story problem has kicked in what makes
us just kind of want to follow them you
know I mean save the cat says they save
a cat which makes us like them because
they do something self-sacrificing and
helpful that's a sort of semi joke you
know premise I think that Blake Snyder
came about just have your character save
a cat but I think what he was really
getting out was a really vital thing
that writers tend to sometimes bypass or
no
understand which is give us a reason to
bond with that character before your
story really kicks in and so I probably
failed in all those and other ways in my
early scripts and maybe some later
scripts that made people go huh needs
more conflict so what about the opposite
what if someone says well I'm never
gonna get notes like that I'm gonna have
it packed with conflict and then it's
actually too much it's not subtle it's
not under the surface like I'm just
thinking of sharp objects I watched the
first episode last night and you can see
seeds planted that the conflict some of
its obvious some of its not and you're
wondering hmm there was a look at the
end with this one character I think
there's good you know and I like hints
at it and then it keeps you hooked in
because you're like I want to see
something go down here but it doesn't
yet yeah well I mean yeah it's like it's
not that you have to hit over hit people
over the head with with constant like
you know screaming matches or fights or
anything like that to me it's that there
has to be a central problem and a
central character faced with that
problem that the audience buys into
early on and says okay I care about this
problem I want to see this problem get
solved for this person by this person
once you have them feeling that way then
you can play out the resolution of that
problem over a lengthy period of time
you don't have to get right to it in a
really you know sledgehammer kind of
manner but the the problem has to be big
enough to begin with it has to be grabby
enough to begin with then how they
evolved in dealing with the problem and
how the problem evolves and if it's a
mystery how the cards get turned over
and the clues get revealed and the leads
get followed up on that's part of the
fun for the audience is that that stuff
takes time you just don't want to have
long periods where none of that's
happening at all and things seem kind of
fine that's what you want to avoid
things are never fine in a story there's
always that simmering you know problem
overshadowing everything I think in a
compelling commercial story where the
audience is going I want to see this
resolved the reason I'm binging on this
is I want to see this problem or these
problems get resolved but what they
really want to see is they want to see
how the problems
build and complicated twist and turn and
evolve and then later get resolved
because you know once it gets resolved
it's kind of over so if you're binging
on 12 episodes or whatever it is you
probably know no real resolution gonna
happen til the end of the twelfth if
then but on the way how its evolving is
the thing that's fun for us to watch as
an audience have you given notes to
someone - hey tone it down this is too
much right here it's too explosive and
it's like almost like beating the the
the reader over the head a little bit I
don't think that happens very much
unless what they're doing doesn't feel
believable to me that's the sort of the
be--and problem is you know believable
and and that's a bigger more common
issue than people might think where
readers are reading their stuff and
going I don't believe this character
would do or say this or maybe it doesn't
it feels contrived in some way it feels
like the writer is trying to force
something that isn't organically coming
out of the lives and desires and
emotions and personalities of the
characters so on to some extent the
characters do have to drive the story
everything they're doing has to feel
like it could and would really happen
they could or would really say or do
those things in those moments so it's
not that I'm ever saying oh there's too
much conflict you're trying to make the
problem too big per se unless in doing
that it's straining believability
because even those stories have easily
something exaggerated about them or even
sometimes a fantastical element that
they're based on like there's a zombie
apocalypse or there's vampires in the
high school or whatever even though they
have that kind of stuff sometimes and
even in a comedy you're exaggerating
characters a little bit for comedy I
believe there still has to be this basis
of reality that we're seeing human
beings that we can accept seem real
doing or saying what we think they would
really do or say in those situations and
a lot of times in a lot of scripts there
will be moments and scenes and
characters that don't feel that way that
feel over-the-top
unbelievable reacting in ways that seem
forced for the sake of more conflict or
more comedy or entertainment value or
more action so that's where I might
sometimes feel that something needs to
be toned down
so that it feels like it's all coming
from a real place when in doubt always I
say go for the real I heard somebody say
this once a professional writer at at a
panel and it's so true
you hope that your concept is compelling
enough people are gonna care there's
something entertaining at its core but
as you start plotting it out I always
say start with what's real at every
moment in the story what would each
character be really thinking feeling
doing at this point given their
situation
how do you make them do things that feel
totally believable and just totally real
audiences love it when it feels real but
still is entertaining and compelling and
all those other things and achieving
that level of realness that feels really
authentic is is difficult but it's
really special when a writer is able to
just write with like authenticity that
is just like I absolutely suspend
disbelief you absolutely have me I
believe these people are real I forget
that I'm watching something fictional so
when you can do that in the context of
having these other elements of a story
then I think you're really in good shape
can you think of a film in particular
that there was like one of the first
that did that for you well I mean I
think most really great and successful
movies and TV shows do have reality do
you have that basis of reality which is
why they work if they didn't have it I
don't think they'd be successful so I
think you see that in most successful
things that there is that sense of I
believe these people and what they're
doing I believe the reality the
situation's the writer has set up having
said that there are certain shows
certain movies that I can think of maybe
not the first that did it but that feel
they did it to a really extreme level
like the wire on HBO that series you
know to me kind of made every other cop
show that it ever come before seemed
almost kind of like cheesy or fake in
comparison because it felt so real and
when you can achieve that level of
realness audiences critics agents
producers they all respond to that if
you have these other kind of elements of
story in place that level of realness
can really make your stuff special so
that's one example the spray
was also a show that even though it was
a real as the wire when I would watch
The Sopranos I would kind of like just
buy it for some reason that was a show
that I felt like I don't feel like I'm
watching actors and writers and
directors I feel like I'm watching these
like real people that are really living
in this subculture at its best which i
think is the reason why shows like The
Sopranos and The Wire are voted like
some of the best written shows of all
time because they obviously did that for
a lot of people even Forrest Gump I mean
I could I could think that that is a
real person that if you go on Wikipedia
though oh there he is and you know yes
and he beat this person in ping-pong and
I mean it's believable enough as wild of
a ride as his life was that that could
be a real person there's just something
about the the writing and and drawing
you into this sort of innocent world
yeah I mean I think you're right I mean
it's yeah it's a very opposite example
where it's a very fanciful story but
somehow it convinces the audience for
those two to three hours that this is a
real thing and nothing is making them go
okay it's not real anymore I don't get I
mean they're people who don't like the
movie but I don't think there's much
that makes people just check out because
it doesn't seem like it could be
plausible you know the characters once
you establish who they are they behave
in ways that make sense based on who
they are and what their psychology and
their backstories are and what their
current desires and situations are and
that's where it's like the writer Eric
Roth in this case is going for the real
I think is taking you know the situation
the people where they're at and saying
what is real to have happen next and
plus he's throwing in some very damaged
supporting characters you know Jenny and
Captain Dan and things like that around
it and so as perfect as Forrest might
seem and that he kind of just is always
able to you know run through no pun
intended sort of situations he has some
very sort of damaged people around them
that are very real and that that part is
also interesting yeah I mean I think if
you look at Lieutenant Dan or Jenny in
Forrest Gump they are they are playing
out their psychology their family
history their
their problems their worst tragedies
that have happened to them and they feel
like it's psychologically real and
that's what I mean when I say Real
Estate's like psychologically based on
who they are think a writer kind of a
fiction kind of has to be a little bit
of a psychologist because you're saying
given this person's history and what
they've been through how would they be
now how would they react in this
situation how would they go about
pursuing whatever they want in their
lives and you know it's gonna vary
greatly based on where they come from
and what led them to this point so yeah
it's not it's not easy to do that really
well but when you do I think audiences
respond by totally buying in and being
compelled by this psychologically real
feeling person that you're putting on
screen or on the page I'd love to hear
your story in terms of was there a
certain film that made you want to be a
writer your choice in your college major
yeah when I was in high school the film
the world according to GARP had a big
impact on me it was about a writer
whose mother was a nonfiction writer and
my mother was also a kind of aspiring
nonfiction writer very different from
that character but still that that movie
was the first movie that I was like
there's something that I related to in
that movie that was different from any
other movie I'd ever seen it made me
think about you know somebody wrote that
you know which was a phrase that writers
guild used in an ad campaign once to get
respect for writers somebody wrote that
they had all these lines of dialogue on
billboards you know don't forget a
writer wrote that an actor didn't just
come up with that set but anyway the
world according to GARP had an impact
and I think when I went to college I I
knew I wanted to pursue something
creative that involved writing whether
it was fiction or screenwriting or maybe
even music and so after a year or two I
settled in on on becoming a film major
and and maybe trying to become like a
writer director because a lot of my
favorite movies at that time were writer
director movies like you know Woody
Allen movies of that era like late 70s
early 80s and so I did I pursue
being a film major in my undergraduate
in Ohio which is my home state and got a
four-year degree BFA and motion picture
production which of course guarantees
you a job in the industry immediately
when you show up with that and I just
thought I was gonna move to Los Angeles
and become an assistant because I kind
of knew you know that whole starting the
William Morris mailroom kind of thing
that I knew that that was a thing you
could do there were people that had
moved out to LA from Dayton Ohio where I
was from before me who'd gone to my film
school before me who had these kind of
jobs working as assistants at the
studios and stuff so I decided that's
gonna be my path I'm gonna get it my day
job will be one of those kind of jobs
where I'll be like a secretary and I'll
just be writing on the side and so
that's what I pursued and was lucky
enough to get into the Fox Studios kind
of in-house temp pool where somebody in
the human resources department had all
these temps that every day they would
assign to these different jobs
throughout the studio where they needed
somebody to fill in for a day or a week
or a month or whatever because some
assistant was on maternity leave or out
sick or had just left and they hadn't
replaced them yet so I got my taste of
all these different kinds of jobs
throughout 20th Century Fox and the Fox
Network you know everything from like
legal department to accounting and
finance like very corporate departments
but also some of the eventually the more
creative side where you're working on a
TV show or working for a production
company which is of course what you
really want if you're an aspiring writer
and so I did that for a number of years
and eventually got assigned to Tom Hanks
his production company just as a temp
which turned into a full-time assistant
job working there where it was basically
him and his his main assistant who went
with him on location and had been with
him for years and me I was like the guy
in the office like answering the phone
and opening the mail he was off shooting
Forrest Gump for like five months at one
point you know on the East Coast and I
was the only one there in the office
kind of holding down the fort so to
speak at his little production company
that was based at Fox at that time so
while I was doing that I was writing
scripts on the side and I had worked as
a writer's assistant on the
show picket fences right before I work
for Tom Hanks and got to know other
people at my level other assistants
which is a really helpful thing to do
you know they say do you have to move to
Los Angeles to be a screenwriter you
don't have to it helps and but one of
the main reasons it can help is if
you're the kind of person that gets a
job in the business like that where
you're around people doing what you want
to be doing and you meet people at your
level who are also trying to do the
kinds of things you want to do and you
can sort of help each other and that
certainly worked out for me because I
switched from writing features on spec
to I took a class at UCLA extensions
writers program where I have taught now
in recent years myself on sitcom writing
I started writing a spec script for the
show Fraser in that class and then when
it was done I showed it to this friend
I'd work with on picket fences he was a
fellow assistant but also an aspiring
writer who had just gotten an agent and
she liked the Fraser and was willing to
show it to her agent and the agent liked
the Fraser enough to want to sign me so
I got this agent while I was still
working as an assistant for Tom Hanks
and this agent function kind of like
managers do now managers weren't such a
thing back then where she was giving me
notes
you know she signed me off it but then
she immediately wanted me to rewrite it
with all these notes she gave me before
she would send it to anyone and so then
she had me after that was done she had
me start my next one which was a mad
about you and after that of friends so I
was like pumping out these sitcom spec
scripts because in those days when you
wanted to work on staff on a show in the
90s they more valued specs of existing
shows whereas nowadays it's its original
pilots that writers tend to use for
writing samples to get into TV writing
you know a staff job like that which is
normally how you get in is you know you
get hired as like a staff writer on a
show if you're one of the lucky few
fortunate few so that's the direction I
was headed but I still had the the Tom
Hanks really great sort of assistant day
job but I was really starting to think
eventually I'm gonna be a professional
writer now I mean I have an agent she's
sending my stuff out I got some meetings
here and there but then things took a
funny turn an amazing turn which is that
one day Tom Hanks read one or two of
those scripts because his assistant who
I worked kind of under I think right
amended oh you should have Tom read your
you know it'd be fun whatever I don't
know I was never gonna ask him to read
my stuff or help me in any way cuz I
knew this is my job this is he's not
there to help me do that
and he apparently liked the one or two
scripts he read and decided that I had
talent and he told me my talents are
being wasted and he offered me this like
amazing life-changing promotion the week
of my 30th birthday I had a wife and a
kid and she was a teacher and I was
making seven hundred dollars a week I
think or something like that so it was a
really a good time to get a promotion
where I was gonna help him basically
help him develop this miniseries he had
sold to HBO as an executive producer
which was from the earth to the moon
which was about the Apollo space program
he had done the movie Apollo 13 and was
a life long space junkie and at this
point was the biggest star in Hollywood
he had gotten to that point by then and
so he was able to sell this idea for a
miniseries of very expensive 12 hour
miniseries where we would dramatize and
recreate the entire Apollo program right
all these other missions you know so I
then helped him kind of figure out the
sort of outline for that and like find
writers to write the episodes you know
professional screenwriters that were
already established unlike me but
eventually I got to write one of the
scripts and then eventually that script
became a decent script because it took a
long time and then I got asked to help
rewrite some of the other scripts so by
the end of that production from the
earths of the moon I had kind of been an
apprentice producer on the whole thing
so I got a co-producer credit on the
whole thing and I had writing credit or
pieces of writing credit on several
episodes and I just like learned all
this stuff from just being on it from
beginning to end and being able to be
kind of in the middle of it because I
worked for Tom and he was the executive
producer so I was on the set in the
editing room and did everything or
watched everything and so when it won
the Emmy for Best miniseries and all the
other big awards I got to share in those
awards because I was one of the
producers so that was really how I got
my start I was very fortunate and that
the first thing I wrote professionally
not only got produced which you know
most things the writers get paid to
write still don't get produced right you
can make
whole career writing things that don't
get produced not only to get produced
but I was a producer on it and one these
major awards for being that so it was
kind of a fairytale beginning of a
career that hat that I owe to Tom Hanks
and to you know this is a cutting which
you wouldn't think translates into
historical drama about the space program
but I somehow managed to figure out how
to how to write for that series even
though it wasn't the kind of stuff I was
doing on my own from the time that you
got to Los Angeles from Ohio to then you
know working for Tom Hanks and and being
part of these projects was there a
moment where it hits you where you're
like wow this I'm actually doing this
like was there some type of a anything
that happened you're out maybe getting
lunch where you you know it's easy to
lose sort of focus in LA and you're so
busy trying to do something and looking
for a parking spot or an apartment
whatever that it's easy to get lost in
that you're really actually doing what
you set out to do was there a moment
where it hit you I think there were a
few moments it does things tend to
happen in a gradual way and they build
one one on top of the other so it's like
my first day I'm working at a movie
studio exciting I'd get to drive through
the gate they let me in whatever but
then that becomes just an everyday
normal boring thing right and so then
the next thing and the next thing but a
series of things that were the big
things probably what I told you about
when I was offered that promotion was
probably the biggest thing but there
were moments I mean even as an assistant
when Tom Hanks one is back-to-back
Oscars for Best Actor I was the guy that
took the statuette to the Academy the
next day to get the nameplate put on
because that's how they did it I know if
they still do it that way so like
driving in my beat-up Toyota with a
Oscar for Best Actor on my seat that was
a moment for sure there was a moment
during the filming of Band of Brothers
where I got to ride on a private jet
from from London to LA with just Tom
Hanks Steven Spielberg and me we were
the only three people passed and Steven
was like showing Tom these both of us
these like Stanley Kubrick movies and
giving commentary because he was close
friends with Kubrick you know that was
definitely I mean I was already like a
sort of producer on the project and had
meetings and I've worked with
for years by that point but Stephen was
a new thing to be around him and the two
of them and just be us was definitely a
moment that you you know ten years later
will be telling people on YouTube or 15
years whatever it is but yeah there are
a lot of those moments I mean I've got
got to meet and work with you know some
very well known successful great people
and got to be you know you know just see
different levels of hey I've done this
now and I've succeeded at this or this
has happened certainly getting to go the
Emmys and go on stage it's part of the
group it was it was a big moment you
know of course that was a moment that
everybody back home was like oh you've
really done something now that's
definitely Valu validates what you've
been doing when you have that you were
on television on award show next to Tom
Hanks kind of thing in a talks yeah and
it talks yeah do those jobs still exist
anymore in terms of you so there was a
temp pool and I'm not sure how plentiful
sort of this temping is anymore
I think they still exist I mean
certainly that path where you become an
assistant like generally right out of
college in your 20s working for an
agency or a production company or just a
temp at a studio I think that definitely
still exists I don't know if the studio
still have in-house temp poles in the
same way they did then I think they
might have moved more towards
outsourcing it with agencies in those
days they did both but there's
definitely a number of temp agencies
that service the entertainment industry
specifically and if you just google temp
agencies Los Angeles Entertainment that
front page of Google will pretty much
have them all on there and I think it's
probably still fairly easy to apply to
those agencies because they're always
looking for new temps and I don't know
what what testing they do I mean I know
I had to do like typing speed tests and
can you use Microsoft Word and this and
that they probably still do a little bit
of testing and interviewing but to get
registered with one of those agencies I
think is that probably the first step
and not so hard of a step with at least
with some of them and then hopefully
they assign you places where you like it
and do a good job and that gets you
going
let's talk about the hypothetical spec
script let's suppose I want to get on a
show what would be my method to doing
that would I write about an episode that
already exists you know at a
continuation of one yeah in television
these days to get to be in consideration
for getting your first writing job on
staff of a show which means you didn't
sell your own original show you got
hired to write for someone else's show
which is still the much more likely
scenario for a new writer right
people are writing original pilots and
hoping to sell them and get them you
know on in front of an audience of
course and there's always a chance that
that could happen but it's of course
very rare today you know people writing
original pilots you know within the
industry people that have managers and
agents writing original pilots if they
don't already have a big track record
writing for television or film and a lot
of success they're probably writing that
as a writing sample to try and get a job
on staff of a series and what has
changed in the like twenty years since I
was doing that is that back in like the
90s and before the traditional way to
get hired on staff of a series was to
write what they would call a spec
episode of an existing show just what
it's just some successful relatively new
show that people in the industry liked
and respected like Seinfeld was the big
show to do like during it's like second
seasons about the right time where
people are writing these their own ideas
for an original Seinfeld episode that
hopefully reads like a like a really
good episode of Seinfeld like you read
the script and you go this feel like it
could be on that show it would be a
really good episode that show they
captured the voices it's very funny
etc etc not easy to do really well easy
to do mediocre ly not easy to do well
enough that people go wow which of
course that's what you want when you're
a screenwriter it's like to get that WoW
is rare and sought-after right so back
then very few people wrote original
pilots if they weren't already
established cuz there was nothing to do
with them they weren't looking for
original pilots as writing samples as
much they want to know that you could
write in another writers voice an
episode of a show that already existed
which of course is what you would be
doing if you got hired on staff for some
reason in the last 20 years that is
shifted a lot what I've heard
anecdotally is where in those days 80%
of it was specks of existing shows
nowadays it's more like 80% our original
pilots that people are writing and that
is what is getting the managers and
agents and gain them their first jobs on
a series on a writing staff people still
do write specs of existing shows I think
you definitely need to write them to get
into some of the big fellowships that
some of the studios and networks offer
which are great ways to try and break
into TV writing but what's much more in
vogue is writers writing original pilots
for series that they came up with and
those pilots become their main writing
sample or samples that they use to try
to first get a manager and then get an
agent which you usually kind of have to
go step by step and then have their
managers and agents sending them to
production companies showrunners
executives at the studios and networks
and streaming services to try to get you
noticed as a potential TV staff writer
and so how long would these spec scripts
be I mean so it's gonna be like half our
content or it's gonna be this would be
the same length as a typical script for
the show you're writing for well if it's
original a show of the ilk of what
you're writing in other words if you're
writing a one-hour clearly a network
style drama it's gonna be about you know
it's gonna be like a 45-minute because
there would be commercials and then how
many pages that translates to you know
they say and then the page you can go a
little long in a spec I would say a
one-hour pilot maybe like 60 pages would
probably be the max you would want to go
for for an original pilot you're really
trying to sort of like copy what
successful shows that are similar to
yours would do in terms of length so
it's really helpful to read scripts not
just watch episodes of the kind of shows
that you inspire you that you would want
to you know write something in that
genre whether it's like an HBO type show
or a Netflix type show nowadays those
services have shows that can have
different length episodes and different
length scripts so that they're not a
standard like 20 one-minute half-hour
comedy on ABC kind of thing it's a
little more there's some flexibility I
think so you don't have to be too
nervous about the exact right number of
pages but generally you're emulating
what is standard for the kind of script
that you're writing why do you say it's
so hard to make a great
spec script it's easier to make a
mediocre one what's the well when you're
wearing a spec episode of an existing
show I think it's it's easy ish to write
something where the characters talk kind
of how they talk on the real show you
know and you have the kind of jokes that
you can imagine they would kind of have
but maybe they're not great jokes but
they're just kind of like sort of okay
jokes and the kind of story and kind of
behavior of the characters that is their
typical behavior like it's not so hard
to sort of mimic that it's hard to mimic
it in a way that's as good or better
than the actual produced show is because
really for one of those scripts to stand
out I was always told it has to actually
be better than an average episode it has
to feel like why haven't they done this
episode it's like a great idea it's
perfect for the show it's really funny
it's really memorable if it's a comedy
obviously you're going for the funny and
that's just hard to do really well it
looks it looks easy which is why I try
to do it it looks easy to write a show
that you know that's a good show you
come up with your own ideas for stories
for an episode it but to do it on a
level that would that someone would hire
you based on it is not easy and and
normally the show you wrote it for is
not gonna hire you they're probably not
even gonna want to read it they probably
will be tougher on it than any other
show would because they know their show
so well and they probably aren't looking
for writers because they're already on
the air and a hit so typically when
you're breaking into television you're
breaking in with a staff writing job on
a brand new show that no one's ever seen
before you may not even love the show
but it's where they offered you a job
based on reading your stuff and it may
be a show that gets cancelled in its
first season because most of them do but
that's kind of like the life of a what
they call baby right or a writer
breaking into television and working on
staff but most of that doesn't apply as
much today because people are writing
original pilots instead of specks but
obviously it's really hard to write an
original pilot that impresses people to
perhaps harder because now you're coming
up with characters and a whole situation
that they don't know anything about and
you have to make them you know care
about these characters be entertained
being treated and all that kind of stuff
and all the problems of the show have to
be really compelling whereas if you're
writing a spec episode of an existing
show a lot of
that has already been done for you right
you just have to write a variation on
something that someone else has already
established
maybe that's why nowadays those aren't
valued as much because people can say
well you didn't have to do as much to do
that on the other hand when you write on
staff of a show a big part of your job
is mimicking the voice of the showrunner
being able to execute the show in a way
that they would like the way they would
have done it which is a not a skill that
every writer has so to show you can
write somebody else's show in their
voice really well I think still is a
very valuable thing but the industry is
more interested in original pilots for
writing samples despite that I think
these days but you say it's rare that
let's suppose Seinfeld I'm writing you
know it's still in existence that I'm
writing that that I'm submitting this to
and thinking that I'm going to be in the
writers room for Seinfeld know I'm
submitting it for friends or something
well you're submitting you're not even
making for friend you're submitting for
some show that hasn't been on the air
yet I mean that's the reality because
you you know you're your agent would be
the one doing all the submitting right
so first you have to impress an agent
enough to get an agent but once you have
an agent they're gonna be submitting
these these new potential writers to all
those brand new shows that just found
out they got a series order and now they
have to staff up shows they've already
been on the air they already have a
staff they may have one person leave and
they fill one vacancy but basically
they're already there so you're never
almost never gonna get on a successful
existing hit show that you love or that
you would have written a spec of you're
gonna use that spec to get on some brand
new unknown show that you may or may not
love or may or may not be right for but
it's they thought you were right for it
based on your script so there you go so
Eric we've taken some questions from
some viewers that have been willing to
leave them on our community table for
YouTube we have so many here and
apologies to those we don't get to one
of which is from Melissa rose and
Melissa writes is there one thing you
feel is essential for a screenwriter
slash writer to know before beginning
before starting well there are a lot of
things but I mean I think that the
reason I wrote this book about you know
making the idea process a priority is
really based on my feeling that
need to know that choosing the idea that
you're gonna write is so important and
so essential and not easy to pick an
idea that's gonna be a worthwhile thing
to write worthwhile meaning it would
have a chance at you know moving you
forward in the industry it's always
worthwhile to write and have the
experience perhaps for yourself and your
own learning and growth but from a from
a commercially marketable can move my
career forward standpoint to meet the
probably most important thing which is
why the you know I wrote this book about
this is is to understand what the
elements are of a viable story idea and
to make coming up with one your main
priority and take the time and get the
feedback necessary on your just ideas
before you launch into six months or a
year or even several years writing and
rewriting a script because you can write
and rewrite a script endless times but
to make it somewhat better but if it's
based on an idea that really was always
gonna have a tough time moving forward
no matter how you execute it a manager
an agent would call that somewhat wasted
time so that's probably my first obvious
self-serving answer based on my book
being about what makes sense maybe we
can go back to actually some more of the
words in this um problem acronym so
original you know we hear so much of
that it's got to really have this
writers voice and all that and and and
got to be this fresh sort of but hasn't
so much already been done it seems like
it'd be very challenging today to have
something quote-unquote original it is
tough I think to be really original and
you know it goes back to your question
about writing things that are really
personal to you you know sometimes the
most original things do come from taking
your real life or taking something you
witnessed or experienced and using that
as fodder for materials so there there
is there can be a value for that if you
can also do what I talked about which is
find a way to have perspective on it so
you can make it viable entertaining
compelling to you know millions of
people that don't know you it's not an
easy thing to do but you know
originality is it's a tricky one
because you can only be so original
because if so many things have already
been done right so many types of story
genres and types of story situations I
mean I just saw eighth grade last night
yeah which you know it was a very
original voice but it's about something
that we've seen four million examples of
which is a kind of misfit teen who the
popular people are mean to trying to
find their way in the social universe of
school like is there anything that's
been done more often than that but yet
you watch the movie and because it felt
authentic and real and specific and
vivid and done not in exactly the way
we've seen it before and it had some
currency because there was a whole
social media aspect to it where she has
like a vlog and she's on Instagram all
the time you know it feels like it's
very much about that problem for today's
eighth graders in a certain setting so
you update it you make a current you
make it specific I think that's the
thing it's not that it has to be an idea
that is so out there and different and
special because sometimes that can be a
trap if you try to be too original
sometimes you end up writing things that
are contrived or hard to believe or hard
to understand because your focus is on
it has to be different from everything
else when a writer focus too much on
originality I wrote in this book
sometimes they're doing at the expense
of these other important elements of
what makes a viable story idea like it
may not be as compelling or as
entertaining or as relatable or these
other things because they're mainly
focused on yeah but no one's ever seen
it before doesn't matter though if no
one's ever seen it before if it doesn't
grab the audience or the reader and the
ways that great stories always have so
you always have to balance the need for
originality with those other elements
that being said you're right that an
original voice is highly valued in a new
writer but it's like finding a way to
have that original I think Authentics a
better word that authenticity where
things feel so real so believable but so
like well observed
and unique and we haven't seen it quite
this way before because something in
this writers way of seeing the world and
people came up with this version of it
that is very memorable even if it's
within the context of something that is
somewhat familiar you know like a like
if you look at Napoleon Dynamite in its
day kind of the same
thing very original voice but it's about
an awkward teen who doesn't fit in and
people you know push him into lockers
you know kind of thing but when you
watch it you're mainly focused on the
authenticity the originality of it not
noticing that this is a story form or a
genre or a type of story problem that
we've seen endless variations on before
us it's kind of like you're taking
something that's been done in terms of a
genre usually but you're putting a very
fresh unique current specific spin on it
right I'm not thinking of pretty and
pink so so that first sort of you know
our generation that was sort of the the
misfits movie especially female
character and just what would that still
work today but yeah you add in the
vlogging element and I haven't seen
eighth grade that's on my list but
something where you know she's in this
sort of town and she sees like the sort
of the the Scioscia and I know
associated it's it really used these
days but and sort of that went looking
up and looking to aspire you know and so
I think anybody can relate to that
that's that's a universal thing but yeah
you throw in the vlogging element the
social media but yeah that's sort of the
high school party that everybody cringes
that you go to and and and hope to be
noticed but you know they don't really
see you and you sort of blend into the
background type of the thing do you feel
that it's still possible though to do
that story over and over again I know
you said you've you've added in the or
they they've added in these new things
the the social media and the things that
are current today but that that story is
very universal whether it's male or
female yeah I mean I I do I think it is
possible and Bo Burnham proves it with
that example that you can do this thing
we've seen so many times you can
instantly call up other movies that have
that same component I mean it has that
high school party that the character
walks in and is petrified and doesn't
get noticed or gets noticed in a
negative way it has that very scene but
it has a unique version of that scene
we've never seen before that feels real
and feels very well observed and is very
entertaining and emotional to watch so
to me that's the key thing don't try and
reinvent the wheel in terms of genre or
types of story problems but bring
something fresh specific real and
original
to your treatment of that of that sort
of genre element that we know is
universally relatable because that's one
of the really hard things is to make
sure that what you're putting out there
is gonna be relatable to millions of
people and the kinds of story situations
that are going to be have probably been
explored many times before because there
aren't an infinite variety of them there
are certain core elements that you tend
to see repeated over and over again in
successful stories that's why I love
Blake Snyder's tens on resent the cat
it's my favorite thing about that book
and I always work with those 10 John
Roos when I work with writers writing
screenplays because I think he really
pinpointed like the kinds of human
situations that we've seen work over and
over again in successful movies and
there were variations on each but there
are certain key core elements that are
present and to sort of realize which one
you're going for and then to really try
and fulfill its elements I think is a
really helpful tool for writers coming
up with ideas for films well so the last
letter in your acronym for problem is
meaningful
so taking let's say eighth grade or
Napoleon Dynamite or pretty-in-pink or
whatever in that sort of that high
school you know not fitting in genre
what would be what's the meaning that's
a movie like that could give because you
could just see it as well it's just yeah
hey everybody I had a tough in high
school it doesn't matter if you were
popular it doesn't matter if you were
bullied everybody had it tough in some
degree so where's the meaning in that so
I think if you walk away going what
everyone had tough in high school what's
the big deal that means that movie
didn't affect you very much and it
probably wasn't meaningful to you right
so meaningful to me is when we talk
about like theme and what's a movie
really about underneath its its surface
plot what's the message or what's the
underlying issue being explored or
issues and also what the audience takes
home with them do they feel impacted by
do they feel it had some meaning to
their own lives as opposed to I just
watched these people have this thing
happened and I sort of forget about the
next moment or it doesn't really nothing
that I saw feels like it impacts me in
my view of the world and people at all
it's just a fictional story and when
it's over it's very forgettable so
meaningful in some ways is the
most optional of these seven elements
that I put in the book because certain
movies like let's say transformers or
something don't necessarily to be need
to be so meaningful and have such a
strong theme like that and I'm not
dissing transformers or saying that it
doesn't have any theme or meaning but
certain kinds of movies if they're so
entertaining and they have such a
punishing problem that is relatable
enough to a universal audience which
when you have life-or-death stakes you
usually have that one covered you know
life-altering stakes what's the other
one original and believable if it's
executed in ways that do all those
things you could have a hit movie on
your hands even if it isn't that
meaningful but what most writers trying
to break in are trying to do our movies
that do have a lot of meaning because
that's often what writers are most
attracted to is the theme and the
character arc and that kind of stuff
that tends to give something meaning I
also think we talked about the
originality and the whole executing
something in a brand new way that feels
very specific and well observed and real
that helps give it meaning to people
because if they feel like they're just
watching this contrived thing that was
just there to entertain them but it
nothing about it felt real or felt like
oh and my life and my kids are my memory
of childhood I can I went through that
or it like touches me then it's not
going to be meaningful to them so
meaningful is maybe the most optional
and the final one of the seven to
consider but it can be the most
important one in the end that like puts
you over the top because if your script
makes people really feel something and
almost makes them think about their own
lives in some way even as you know a
hardened professional reader in the
industry if it really makes them feel
like I didn't just watch these remote
people but I connected and it feels like
it explored something about the human
condition that's relevant to me and
everyone that's really powerful we'll go
back to another viewer submitted
question and this is from wicked West
films nice name by the way what advice
would you give to a writer to make their
stories stronger with more depth and
meaning well we kind of just talked
about meaning a little bit and yeah
well I mean it's gonna sound kind of
but it's kind of like these seven
elements to really understand and
explore each of them try to like hit
each of those is what makes to me makes
things powerful like when you make sure
that what you're writing is a punishing
problem it is relatable universally
relatable situation for your characters
there is something original something
believable
the stakes are life-altering for the
characters all of that is what makes
something powerful you also also want to
be entertaining and it's gonna mean
something to people if you're exploring
something that is not just your surface
story plot but is something that has
some depth for the characters it's like
if the characters feel something deeply
and are going something going through
something that the audience connects
with emotionally and feels like they
become bonded like we talked about with
the character where they feel like it's
happening to me you know what they're
going through I feel like I'm
experiencing it that's what really gives
it a powerful impact so but all of these
elements of story are all ways in which
you achieve that because like the bigger
the problem is the more important it is
to solve the more of the characters
under kind of siege trying to solve it
the more you're gonna have a better
chance at the audience connecting that
way so so much of it has to do with your
choice of idea and the kind of the genre
that it's in and what your basic premise
of your story is to make sure that it's
going to have the ability to have that
powerful impact so the save the cat
moment or this relatability does this
have to happen in the middle toward the
end in the beginning I mean even in the
sharp objects there's just a moment
where amy adams stops for a gentleman
who's about to cross and they had this
quick exchange and she gestures for him
till i go ahead and he says kind of like
no you go ahead and then she nods she's
not like stubborn about it or no no no
go go go
she's like and you you see okay I trust
her I like her in that moment but then
there's a lot of things that happen that
where you're like mm not quite quite
sure about this person but that little
moment right there and that happens
fairly soon makes her relatable I think
it does help classically in the
beginning if the character if you're all
about making the character be someone
that the audience can connect with in
the very opening pages so that that can
have to do with them being a nice person
like that but it can also have to do
with them having problems that we can
instantly relate to and feel something
about so we even if they're not that
nice like in eighth grade she's not
necessarily so nice but she's going
through such just terrible problems that
most people can relate to you can't help
but start to get emotionally connected
so to me it's that it's a combination of
likeability and the problems the less
likeable they are the more immediate
obvious and big the problems need to be
for the audience to have something to
grasp on to emotionally I think when in
doubt it's good to also be likable but
there are certainly some stories that
succeed with characters that aren't
necessarily classically likable but I
would say it can be very
counterproductive if you're if your
character starts the movie kind of a
jerk because you're trying to arc them
into a nicer person at the end if they
don't have really massive problems
they're facing that make us relate
despite them being a jerk it can be hard
for the audience to want to engage and
stay with in my opinion a character
that's just kind of really unlikable
it's it's rare that that can work I'm
not saying never but it's rare and I do
see a lot of scripts where that's the
the the choice the writer made to make
the character unlikable in the beginning
because they're so focused on character
arc but it can undermine the story if
they're so unlikable that we have no
reason as an audience to really want to
stay with them it's not as easy to get
an audience to want us to join you on
that character's journey as you might
think you kind of have to make them want
to I think so so establish that fairly
early I think interesting okay okay
because those kind of those first few
that first impressions count kind of yes
interesting so we have another viewer
submitted question from leo hi Leo how
would an inexperienced writer enjoy
writing if their writing skills aren't
spectacular but they love the idea they
have how do they not get discouraged and
lose motivation afterward well that's a
definite challenge for all writers is
getting discouraged and losing
motivation you know it's it's really a
mental or psychological game to stay
with it in the face of maybe other
people not being excited about the stuff
that you've written which I think all
writers go through I certainly have gone
through and still go through at times
with stuff that I am writing so you do
have to you know it's this weird
combination of following your passion
and your beliefs and your instincts and
what's interesting to you while also
listening to sort of feedback and
guidance about what makes them a
compelling story for others now some
people I suppose can enjoy writing and
not care that anyone else ever gets it
or likes it in that case you're you
don't have such a problem because you
just I'm writing because I enjoy it I
don't necessarily even show it to other
people but most writers don't want to
just do that they wanted to show it to
others and have others like it well
that's where it's out of our control
suddenly because others are not us right
so it's easy once others don't respond
well to get discouraged but the reality
is every script that anyone has ever
written probably didn't impress many
people on its journey to wherever it got
to in other words it's just hard to
write something rare to write something
that people are gonna give you the
reaction that you wanted from it for
most people starting out that's an
elusive thing to get to that place so
it's kind of like you you have to have
this kind of almost as an approach of
I'm just doing this anyway I'm learning
and growing and I'm going to get there
and like not let anybody's criticism
derail you from that intense focus on
this is what I want to do and I'm gonna
continue to follow my voice but my voice
or my instincts are going to change
somewhat when I study the craft and when
I get feedback from others and I just
look to make that feedback useful as
opposed to devastating you know what is
the thing that maybe is missing for
people in my work based on the feedback
I'm getting and can I wrap my head
around what's missing and why and apply
that understanding to either the next
draft or the next thing I write for most
people it takes many scripts over many
years to get to the point where you have
a chance at the stuff you're writing
really being successful with others who
might matter to you
so I think just also knowing that
writer goes through that and there's
this book called the war of art by
Steven Pressfield that's a great one for
this because he really talks about how a
part of us is afraid and resistant to
just doing whatever it is we said we
want to do and we'll use any excuse to
not do it including others criticism or
our own self-criticism and it's kind of
like to be productive and to stay with
it you just have to sort of push all
that aside and just continue going and
turn the criticism into something
productive instead of letting it get you
down including your own self-criticism
which is really the hardest the hardest
thing I think is to be able to kind of
put that aside use it when you need to
critique and analyze your work but not
always be in the critical mode because
you're in the critical mode you're not
in the creative mode it's kind of like
you have to switch one off to get to the
other the creative mode is a more loose
free open relaxed trusting mode where
ideas just sort of come but in your if
you're in that mode of what's wrong with
it and what do other people say is wrong
with it and what do I think is wrong
with me
ideas generally don't come that are good
ideas in that state so you almost have
to like work on managing your own
emotional state and your own viewpoint
in order to be able to get to your best
material I know I've mentioned this
before but are not updation the two the
two Nikolas KITT you know Charlie
Kaufman and just that the one that's
just invents lightning and the other one
that that just over thinks everything
and how paralyzing that is yeah yeah
Donald Kaufman the brother has a may not
be writing the greatest material but
he's got a positive attitude toward
himself and others that is infectious
and leads to a lot of ideas coming that
do end up being successful in the
context of that movie right but I mean
it's a great because we've seen that so
many times in life where that really
does it's a self-fulfilling prophecy in
either direction and so and I think
writers are especially prone because
they're always in their heads and
they're overthinking things that's the
nature of why they're writers in some
sense angry at but it also can really
handicap them way so do you remember
when you sort of let up on yourself even
if you still deal with
you know I mean we all do seeing
ourselves whether it's you know on tape
or whatever is is always sort of a
cringe-worthy moment for everybody I
think but do you do you remember when
you sort of were able to come to more of
a Zen place with that it's an everyday
practice every day it's a challenge to
feel like to sort of put on the the
right mindset to be creative and to be
sort of like allowing and trusting and
letting go and not being self-critical
to self-critical so it's not a one-time
thing that you get to and you're just
like oh I don't do that anymore you may
get more used to how you can shift your
kind of energy into that other mode and
so you have a way to do it but I like
what the war of art would say is that
that resistance that's in you is like
trying to stop you and it will do it
every day
it's just like there's a part of us
that's going to be self-critical to the
point of paralyzing or counterproductive
or self sabotaging so I really do think
you have to learn how to everyday sort
of fight the battle or you know see it
for what it is and not let it just take
you over completely in your thinking so
that you have a choice and can get to
that place where you can move forward
but I don't think it ever like
completely just goes away we had a
question come in from a viewer Jacob he
writes how do you share your ideas
without getting run over by other
writers or bullying them without getting
run over by them or bullying them how do
you share your ideas yeah I'm assuming
that it would mean you know like people
kind of poking holes in your idea and
and allowing them maybe to sway you from
your voice I'm just assuming sorry dude
that's the tricky part yeah I mean you
can't avoid I mean pick who you share it
with wisely and pick the time that you
share it and the reason why you're
sharing it and what you're looking for
from sharing it and what you tell them
you're looking for when you share it but
even if you do all those things other
people are out of our control and they
might come back to you with opinions and
reactions that are very you know
unhelpful to you or emotionally
discouraging or devastating to you and
you mean
be able to avoid that I mean you can
certainly work on handling your own
reactions but you can't control what
they're gonna say much as you might try
but if you're conscious about all those
things and sort of being targeted and
who you're sharing and why and all those
things and also noticing that they may
say things I don't like and I don't have
to let it destroy my opinion about
whatever I'm writing however I am open
I'm doing it because I'm open to hearing
other opinions and I want to have a
sense of how others are reacting to it
any one person is not enough though it's
probably you need a consensus of people
and people who know something about what
you're trying to do people that
understand the craft are a more valuable
opinion than just kind of friends or
even other aspiring writers may not be
as valuable of an opinion to you so you
always have to take what others say with
somewhat of a grain of salt I think
while being open to if I get a lot of
the same opinion maybe there's something
worth looking at there I think it's a
lot of it is you have to be like a
detective who's interested in knowing
what are the things that aren't working
for people and then I'll figure out why
and I'll figure out how to solve them if
they say you should do this other thing
instead don't listen to that don't try
to do there fixes but listen to what
their issues are which they may not even
be articulating cuz people try to be
helpful and tell you what if you did
this instead what you really want to
know is why do you not like what I did
do and people sometimes don't want to
say it because it's too hurtful like I
was bored I didn't care stuff like that
or they may not even know how to
articulate they just might know I didn't
like it you know which isn't helpful
which is why we try to codify some of
these things of what makes someone like
or not like something right so we can
learn from that so I think it's um you
know trusting that your own voice has
value and that you will find your way to
address whatever problems you decide you
agree our problems takes the power away
from the other random subjective people
who are gonna say whatever it is they're
gonna say I like that I like becoming a
detective and trying to solve it because
in that sense you're taking out some of
the personal feelings from it almost
you're almost you're acting as if you're
a third party and then it's less
you're you're less upset about it yeah
that's excellent so you're not something
that you're able to practice on a daily
basis I know you know 6 a.m. hits and
it's it's a new day for all of us in
many different things that we deal with
but is that something that you try to
really implement yeah I'm very careful
and selective about when I share stuff
and who I share it with because I know
I'll have a tendency to get very upset
depending on what people say and
sometimes it can threaten to derail me
from whatever it is I'm trying to do or
thinking there's any value in it so I've
really learned to be to really be
careful and to do it with the right
people at the right times for the right
reasons at the right times interesting
at the right times in the process cuz
sometimes you're ready it really helps
if you've moved on to another project
and you're not even thinking about this
one anymore
to then show it to people because then
if they don't like it as much you
already have this other one that you're
now interested so I'm a big believer in
putting one down maybe not even show it
to anyone right away work on something
else come back to the first one and
you'll have new perspective and you'll
see things you want to change so you
make your own changes you never had to
show it to anyone at that point right
but eventually when you do show it maybe
have a couple other things that you're
working on so that that one scrip isn't
your whole world anymore right because
when you're in the middle of it it's
your baby and you better not have your
baby get abused by other people right so
it helps to get that distance from it
and a lot of it is you get your own
distance from it you'll be able to give
yourself notes that you couldn't do when
you were in the middle of it and you
finished it to some extent whether it's
um it's the first draft right where it
worries you're not you know I'm gonna
throw this thing away forget it someone
so said this because you've you've
actually gone through it so that's
that's interesting and it's almost like
a form of protection in a way it is yeah
it's another thing I got from the war of
art he talked a Steven Pressfield
somewhere I noticed him saying he would
like finish a project every six months I
said to myself a while back I'm gonna
write two scripts a year to the point
where I feel they're they're kind of
finished they've gone through multiple
drafts of my own notes maybe no one
else's notes have yet come into play but
they've really been rewritten
significantly based on my own notes and
the way I get there is by taking a pause
moving
coming back a couple months later to
like finish one but always have multiple
scripts in the hopper so some are done
some are semi done some you've just
started and so it becomes a little more
of a factory as opposed to I have this
one project I've been working on for
three years and it's all I ever think
about every day and if someone doesn't
like it I'm devastated you know that is
not the most helpful way to go and I've
done that so another viewer submitted
question from Nolan Putnam what's the
most helpful habit you've created in
regards to screenwriting that's allowed
you to become a professional that's a
great question is there one habit that's
been the most helpful probably we've
talked about most of them probably the
most important perspective has been to
see it as something I'm always learning
and I'm always growing and that's okay
it's not like I'm supposed to know it
all and be perfect at it and the things
that I write are gonna just be great
automatically and others are gonna love
them to see it more as it's an ongoing
quest of kind of a self development self
education I'm learning with everything
that I write what works better and and
and not as good so that it's like it's
like this this journey of development
that you sort of like are gonna enjoy
the journey
as opposed to I have to get to a certain
place which it's easy to feel that way
because the world works that way where I
have to get the agent I have to get the
sale I have to get something produced I
have to raise the money and make my
movie like there's all these goals we
might have in the world and a lot of
times they're out of our control and if
you focus only on those goals like what
I can get what I can achieve instead of
what can i express how can I just do
what I decide I want to do which is be a
writer and be learning and growing and
find some satisfaction in that journey
because when you turn it into there have
to be these quantifiable results in
terms of money or others reactions or
whatever then you're putting all your
power in this thing that may or may not
ever happen that you can't for sure make
happen no matter what you do so I think
that attitude
it might seem counterproductive because
it's like well to be six
you wanna you know professional you want
to focus on the professional goals right
well you you do to some extent and you
are open to feedback and you are listen
you know you are educating yourself I
didn't say just go in a hole and just do
what you want to do and never and shut
the outside world out I'm saying engage
with the world with feedback with
education with trying to understand and
get better so its growth but making it a
positive growth for yourself that is
about making me better and making my
writing better not making my results
better because when you focus on how do
I give more how do I write something
that's really going to impact people
more how do I do that how do I figure
out how to do it how do I get better at
it
you're then about giving to other people
and you will achieve success I believe
more when you succeed at giving more you
will get more automatically as opposed
to how do I get the success how do I get
the breaks how do I get the right person
to read it how do I get people to like
it it's more how do I create something
so wonderful that people will just
automatically like it I'm not even
concerning myself with that so it's like
taking the power into your own hands and
being about how you can improve your
stuff and yourself as a writer having
that approach I think is a is a strong
or healthier approach that's gonna lead
to success more than if you do it the
other way yeah that's amazing because I
mean especially to if you do live here
in Los Angeles which you said that you
know necessarily have to but it
definitely helps you're bombarded every
second with reminders whether it's
billboards or someone going by you of
somebody else that's higher up on the
proverbial sort of food chain and it's
kind of thrown in our face and it's it's
really wonderful to think of the
unplugging from that because that's
almost the anti sort of culture here and
and then I mean was that something that
was always a part of your makeup or you
had to learn oh no I have to learn I
mean I still it's again it's like an
everyday practice that thing again right
an everyday practice of being about I'm
just about the purity of expression and
growth and learning
and improving as opposed to the how do I
get the result that I want from others
it's because we don't naturally do it
that way we have to sort of like decide
that's how I'm going to approach this
instead right and I guess to in the last
few years and not to get too morbid but
we've seen people who have achieved
tremendous success obviously not be
happy and then you have to ask yourself
within why am I doing this yeah you know
and it has to be essentially and is is
sort of you know follow your bliss as it
sounds you know sort of bumper sticker
on the back it has to be about that
because you know we do see so many
people that have achieved these amazing
results and the end result for them show
that it wasn't enough I do think it
really is about making the daily
practice journey writing whatever
enjoyable being at peace enjoying what
you're doing each day finding a way to
make it that way so that the journey is
a positive journey and not be so caught
up in the destination because if you
enjoy what you're doing you're going to
do it more you're gonna do it better
you're gonna want to learn more but it
comes from a certain level of confidence
and trust that it's gonna it that it's
what you're doing is worthwhile and if
you measure that only in like money or
career statistics you know you may never
get there and you may always be insecure
about that so but people that want to
write usually there's more of like a
passion more of a purity of I just want
to do this for some reason and so if you
can really hold to that as opposed to
thinking that what what the results are
of doing it is what matters so much you
probably have a better time doing it
you'll be happier you'll be more
productive and prolific and the results
usually actually will follow from that
just real quickly when you before you
chose your major for film and television
what was your goal before that what was
your major when I first started college
I I experiment with being an English
major and you know thinking of writing
fiction poetry I because I experiment
with being a music major briefly but I
pretty quickly you know I took some of
the
introductory film classes and I realized
this was the the medium that I really
wanted to try to write for and and you
said just that festivals really aren't
about the laurels I think I heard you
say in another interview I thought that
was actually beautifully put but maybe I
don't know maybe say you didn't say it
but that goes back to what we're talking
about that the end result you know it is
not really what it should be about and I
know it's easy to theorize that it and
and say these things and when then we
all have to kind of live in a reality
that is life and you're competing with
people all the time and that's something
that happens in preschool and that
happens in adulthood but to really have
something that we get from it that's
more than an accolade I think is do you
think that's what keeps you going
in terms of why you continue with it I'm
not sure what keeps me going to be
honest I mean I think that I keep going
like most writers because just like what
I do it's what I've decided I do what I
want to do and I have the I'm engaged
with the challenge of getting better and
and writing things that really fulfill
why I wanted to be a writer there are
the kinds of things I loved that I
wanted to create more of in the world
and yes part of that is well to get out
in the world I'm gonna need other people
to help me do that and finance it or
whatever but it's it's kind of like I
haven't achieved yet what I wanted to
achieve even though I've worked on some
big things and won awards and made a
living as a writer and stuff there's
there's a lot of the kinds of projects
that I always got into this because I
want to do that I still want to do those
and there will probably always be more
of those so I think there's just this
desire to create an express that never
seems to quite go away and it's also
just a chosen field in a career at this
point so it's it keeps me going because
it's just the path that I'm on and and
have chosen I have no reason to unchoose
yeah I mean I could say the same for
film courage and it'd be great to have
videos get this amount of views but at
the end of the day it has to be about
you know the conversation like today's
conversation and that's worth it for us
that's what we do this for so I can see
even though I'm not a screenwriter you
know how it has to be there has to be
something else aside from you know we're
hoping Eric's video gets you know
millions of views or whatever it has to
be that did the process of it was
enjoyable which it has been so thank you
glad here yeah great wait as well yeah